- Yes, just seat yourself,
McCallister.
I'll be back momentarily.
Gene!
- Oh, those are [bleep] done.
- Gene!
- Huh? What?
- Who is this?
This isn't part of the plan.
- This is New Chet.
- Hi.
I'm Darryl.
- I was inspired by your whole
blast from the past situation.
Darryl and I used
to ass-mule liquid cocaine
out of the Bahamas together.
- And we were married.
- Oh, that's right!
We were.
- Right? Yes.
- Oh, for two days.
- Yeah, 'member?
- Oh, my gosh.
Wednesday and--
both: Thursday.
- Excuse me!
- What?
- The burner isn't even on.
his burner's not--
you're cooking over nothing.
- Okay.
- Oh, God.
This isn't going well.
No, no, no, no.
I'm gonna tell him.
- No, no, no, no.
You can't tell him.
It's gonna be fine.
- Get your hair-finger
out of the soup!
- Look, solved.
- He just sucked--
- Darryl is here for a reason,
okay, mon?
- Why are you talking
like a Rastafarian?
- Okay.
- Can you bend at all?
Got it? Okay.
- Thank you.
- Dinner will be here soon,
because I-I'ma get it.
- Thank you.
So nice of you to come tonight.
And I've changed so much
since our..."skyool" days.
- What's with your voice?
- Sort of a global accent.
I'm very world-traveled,
like Madonna Ciccone,
who I've met
at several giant balls.
- Where did you,
uh, travel last?
I love to travel.
- Oh, it's...
all a blur.
Peni--Pen Island.
- Hmm?
- So glad we could do this.
- You mentioned that,
like, 30 seconds ago.
- Mm.
- It actually worked out well
'cause my book signing, um,
was canceled.
- That must make you
feel like...
no one likes your books.
- No.
No, just too many RSVPs.
Had to move it
to a bigger venue.
I'll be hitting up
the B & Nobles
in Pasadena tomorrow.
- Grea--great.
So glad you could come.
- You said that.
- Boom, boom,
shake the room.
- There we go.
- Nah, you haven't seen me
in a bunch of years though, man.
I am grown.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
I've got a house.
I'm in a bowling league.
- What?
- Yeah.
I've got, like, two,
three kids.
- So, you're
not a prostitute anymore?
- No, I'm still a prostitute.
- Oh.
- So, how's married life?
Terribly confining or--
- Ugh.
Alice left me.
We're in the middle
of a divorce right now.
It's ugly.
- I'm so sorry, McCallister.
I didn't--I didn't know.
- Don't be. Actually,
it turned out quite well.
I'm now dating successful
screenwriter Diablo Cody.
She won the Oscar for
"Juno."
- Never heard of it.
- Yes, you have.
- I don't know.
J'you know?
- It's "Juno."
The movie.
- J'you know what movie?
- J'you know that I'm dating
successful screenwriter
Diablo Cody?
- I don't know, like,
what's making me think of this
right now, but I've, like,
always wanted to be a witch,
with, like,
a bubbling cauldron.
- That's super dope, man.
Go for it.
- Thanks. I will.
- Hey, remember that Christmas
when we broke
into that kid's house
but we couldn't steal anything
'cause he was so wily?
- No.
- Yeah, we were casing the place
for weeks posing as plumbers.
I think we even had a name.
- The Wet Bandits?
- Yes!
- Yeah, that's the plot
to "Home Alone."
- Oh, so it didn't happen again
in New York?
- No.
That's "Home Alone 2."